[Music]
off-line compared to online retail is
still actually a very large fraction of
consumer spending so although online is
growing quite dramatically as of now
essentially still about 90 percent of
total retail spending happens in the
offline world and firms are still trying
to figure out how to best promote
products how to best run a price
promotions things of that sort and so we
wanted to go back and see can we
actually use tools that we learned about
it in the online world better types of
measurement and can we bring that back
through your flying world and try to
track things better so we know if I run
an ad online
I typically can track did somebody click
on it did it again to go to my website
how much they spend all this linkage is
much closer and those are often things
that we don't observe in the offline
world right so an online retailer would
know how did this consumer get to the
product you're ultimately purchased we
can observe dubrow sing with a lot of
precision offline does usually no
equivalent traditionally we weren't able
to see how did somebody walk through the
store how did they actually get to the
specific aisle where they then picked up
products and so what we do in the study
is we actually bring in a new
measurement tool that's going to mimic
the way we're gonna observe things
online in the offline world and in
particular what we're going to do is
we're gonna rig consumer shopping cards
if you will with so-called radio
frequency identification tags which
worked like a GPS tracker that allow us
to track exactly how does somebody walk
through the store which category is
godigo do they walk past what do they
eventually end up purchasing
[Music]
if in a particular week the supermarket
is running a beer ad do more people buy
a beer
that we were usually able to observe
even before but now we can also see did
actually more people go to the beer
aisle so did did that advertising
attract people to go to different part
was started they wouldn't have otherwise
gone to and then they made the purchase
if that's true then maybe this
advertising will have positive spillover
to other categories maybe people on
their way to the beer aisle are now
gonna pick up salty snacks other things
and so there's sort of anecdotally a lot
of that sense that we are gonna get
these kind of spillover effect so people
often talk about the fact that milk gets
stored in the back of the store
why because people buy it very
frequently and having it in the back of
the store makes them walk past a lot of
other categories and hence they might
pick up other things that they didn't
plan on buying on their way and so you
could imagine that advertising does
something very similar if advertising
allows me to divert traffic to other
parts of the store then maybe products I
pass on that way also gonna end up in my
purchase basket and so that was
something that we weren't usually able
to observe
[Music]
so for a store manager the good news
here is that advertising is quite
effective beyond just individual product
being advertised so what we find is that
when you advertise a particular brand of
beer sales go up in the beer category as
a whole and that increase comes partly
from the advertised brands but also goes
beyond that
so some consumers presumably just pick
up on effect beers being advertised
today they got reminded of I want to buy
beer and hence we seen increase in beer
sales and that's beyond the individual
product being advertised at the same
time we also find that the effect stops
there so to the extent that stores might
have to hope that driving more people to
the beer aisle through advertising will
then spill over into higher sales for
salty snacks or other categories that
are stocked nearby we find no evidence
for that whatsoever so we think so
things stop at the category level but
they go beyond individual product being
advertised and so hence as we think
about allocating advertising budget
thinking about effectiveness at the
level of the category rather than the
more narrow product level or the broader
store level seems to be the right way to
tackle that managerial decision
[Music]